so
uh a couple a couple well we got some
stuff
but let's let's uh let's start with this
we missed this yesterday and and big big
shout out to alan powell for finding
this
uh owen admits the gummies were never
really poisoned
it's really lit it's a little quick one
but i think it's worth pointing out
this liar that everybody loves i get so
many threats i was talking to vox day
this morning
legend
fox day's a legend legend
of vlog's day this morning legend
and uh i get so many threats that my new
thing is i
i i don't really pay attention to any of
them because
i assume that the purpose of them
is to get me to react and then humiliate
me
that happened uh previously someone said
that they had poisoned a bunch of
gummies
and they wanted my kids to die of poison
and um there had been gummies that were
set like six months ago but i
completely forgot and there was this
long letter about how
it was poisoned to like kill my kids and
i obviously spiraled got the
got the authorities involved and uh and
what happened when you got the
authorities involved
i'm sure there's an ongoing court case
right
and then someone was like yeah you
opened the gummies like six months ago
and i'm pretty sure uh
nimr like ate one and i was like i
didn't
how the hell am i supposed to remember
that and then i tried to track down the
person who emailed me about the poison
gummies
dead ends and so then i was like oh you
know what most a lot of these threats
are just to make me look stupid
yeah the threats make you look stupid
hey owen are you going to apologize to
the people that you doxed on your show
are you going to apologize to the people
who you had your bears i'm sorry but i i
have to
he is we start from scratch because he's
he's meandering around this and it's
making me very angry
yeah you want me to start it again i
want to hear this again sure
get so many threats i i was talking to
vox day this morning
legend and uh i get so many threats that
my new thing is i
i don't really pay attention to any of
them because
i assume that the purpose of them
is to get me to react and then humiliate
me
that happen you have a booger and uh
previously
someone said that they had poisoned a
bunch of gummies and they wanted my
kids to die yeah
and um there had been gummies that were
set like six months ago but i
completely forgot and there's this long
letter about how
it was poisoned to like kill my kids and
i obviously spiraled got the
got the authorities involved and uh
and then by the way he didn't no he's
lying you never did yeah
of course he's lying you're still lying
this is what i mean that's why he heard
him cause i'm like he's all over the
he's he's it's their fault and then he
got the
he is still lying
i was like yeah you opened the gummies
like six months ago and i'm pretty sure
uh
nimr like ate one and i was like i
didn't
how the hell am i supposed to remember
that and then i tried to track down the
person who emailed me about the poison
gummies
dead end and so then i was like oh you
know what most
a lot of these threats no no you're
skipping the part owen
where you falsely accused people two men
gave out their first and last names to a
stream that was being watched by 4 500
people
and told them that they are trying to
murder your child that's pretty extreme
dude that's that on any level that is
now illegal now let's let's
because every time we put these up it's
that the bears are always what are the
remaining few
lackeys and my new by the way that my
new my new tac my new favorite tactic by
the bears is
i'm not even a fan of owen but you guys
are blah blah blah then their name says
you know double penetration bear or
something
it's like yeah you are you're lying i
never
oh you'll know when you see her um by
the way i got my alt account taken away
on facebook
they want me to verify my identity which
one uh mg gray heart
oh that's your oh that's one of your old
ones for old school one so um
verify it no i'm going the other route
what are you doing i'm
asking for an exception because gender i
just wrote please don't deadname me i
literally suffer enough with my
transition as it is
that's one one of the only it's one of
the only options they give you so we're
gonna go with it
let's see what happens because mg if
they try to write back i'm gonna go yeah
i'm not hello i'm gender neutral yeah
hence the initials are you really gonna
do this to me i'm going to see
i'm going to see if this victim would
work it's going to be great
so just to make me look stupid like
they're not even real
like the gummies weren't poisoned
they were just i get i get so many of
those guys
it's one of the reasons i okay if the
gummies weren't poison and listen bears
you call us fat all you want we could
say that we're gammas we're logos
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call
whatever no we're not logos oh we're not
logos
sorry i forget all the little childish
names you people make i'm trying to keep
up with it too
it's too much so whatever you want to
call us that's fine but please
address this for me if he's saying that
he lied
or saying that the gummies weren't
poison where is the video of him
apologizing to the people that he
actually doxed by first and last name
without any verification that they were
guilty after he said he involved law
where's enforcement apology to those
people to and they went through a lot of
[ __ ]
a lot of [ __ ] because of you we've seen
some of the [ __ ] these people went
through because of you owen
all right so you can call us whatever
names you want you might not like us but
you have to understand
what he did was wrong was immoral and
was [ __ ] because he said i was
spiraling spiraling is a good word owen
you currently are even sober you're
still a [ __ ] lunatic
yeah i got a quick and by the way i
think he's booze sober
in my opinion i don't think he's pill
sober and and the thing is too it's
funny because he um
clearly at least when he had the alcohol
he had an excuse
right he doesn't even have that excuse
there's no excuse yeah it's just it's
how he is
banned finger bam bam bam bam bam
because
uh when there's there's so many of those
like weird threats that i can't keep
straight
and they're so uh emotionally
intense that i'm just like
nonsense i don't take any of it
seriously then why did you get the
police involved in dox people you're a
[ __ ] liar owen
you are a [ __ ] liar that would try to
ruin people's lives
because you're the one with the mental
health issues and he has them i'm sorry
he
there's something wrong with him this
this is a normal behavior there's a lot
wrong with him and it's it's
the problem with a guy like that is most
people like him don't ever end up
getting better because
they they'll refuse any help and they
will push people away and he will get to
the point where he even starts pushing
amy away
and he'll start accusing her doing [ __ ]
i mean remember somebody actually wrote
our comments yesterday about
uh does i bet owen's the kind of guy
that doesn't even let amy leave the
house and i'm like
he doesn't they did a stream together
remember we covered that
yep where he said like uh one of the
audience members was asking does amy
have any hobbies and she straight up
said well owen's kind of guy that likes
to have everybody at home
all the time and so i've been doing
crocheting and she was listing off all
these
boring things the kind of things that
yeah like that that a
housewife who's hostage would do for
that's a [ __ ]
hobby uh
but that that was a quick owen update
for those for those of you out there we
haven't forgotten that he [ __ ] docks
people don't let this [ __ ] lie
to you